hello and welcome to this video playing
master giant probably stopped right in
the middle of the name okay I know good
could be something else
okay so whether in exchange French and
let's see what black is choosing it some
rather important decision here for black
if you want to stay symmetrical with
Knight f6 or do something a little bit
more enterprising like this one this is
a more interesting continuation what's a
bit more risky not overly risky but at
least him D still more of an unbalanced
situation now Bishop d6 us normally
played in this position young takes
quite a long time for all that
it's a bit surprising it's not like man
if you play the French you'll get the
exchange regularly some a bit surprised
that he takes so long
okay yeah here black takes on seafoam
it's not and maybe he has found the book
now or anything I don't know yeah oh he
was distracted by something this is
actually oftentimes an explanation for
we yet let's say time spent time
management there's no management really
it's just like there is something going
on that you don't see of course when
you're not able to watch the other
person okay so here we have a
complicated situation black's pawn
structure is really quite bad and he is
not yet to regain the pawn but he's got
the pair of bishops and this is
oftentimes making quite an impact
so Bishop him yeah I think I'll just
take and play this position Queen will
probably capture at Bishop F form yeah I
could Bishop f4 it could be if it takes
on c6 that we got this ending where I'm
a pawn up and then we can see if I can
then there's the question if I can win
it okay it does not happen he played
Queen to g6 okay so what's going on here
he's threatening on f3 of course Bishop
g3 would stop that I'm not so happy with
this move maybe I've got something
better
there's nothing particularly wrong with
this I'm just feelin sorry my voice is
feeling a little bit if you record first
thing in the morning or almost first
thing in the morning sometimes a bit
routine so yeah that was to be expected
all right
what to do now 95 is now possible in the
next move on the next move so how do
this at xe7 make sure that you cannot
destroy my pawn structure and I got 95
on the cards or Bishop d4 something like
that I have the better pawn structure c7
is 0 but weak but opposite colored
bishops are definitely here in effect
this is an odd move why isn't 95 now
good can also chick c7 but let's do this
okay I saw that he will take here of
course
um just that it feels like I'm betting
here if I go knight c6 92 check King h1
94 94 hmm yeah that is probably equal
okay I can also just recapture you know
this is the more more promising way
probably to play it the Queen moves
probably to e6 I has to go to a
successful okay does not have to go
through six so what about this I can now
do two things I can trade Queens and
play rook c1 to play against that big
pawn or I can take on
see six play Roxy won and playing and
sweet porn
not easy yeah man the rook endgame hmm
what's assume I'm not totally certain
not totally certain about this if I take
here if I trade the trade Queens and
then play against the Seaport I'm not
entirely certain about my night it does
not feel all that active and him I mean
it both options are totally one-sided
I can press for wynia forever
which is often the nature of those
positions coming from the French
exchange we have those sometimes you get
those free rolls where you can play for
wind and risk absolutely nothing okay so
he actually he actually offers me that
pawns interesting okay I don't want to
take it right away I mean he's not going
to be able to save it I think well maybe
maybe just rook d7 after watch out for
the time
I feel I'm not yet fully awake so just
wanted some quicker moves on
okay so much ink it hmm yeah that's not
good
really yeah I did not make the best of
my chances him oh it's still a draw but
it was not exactly necessary just have
to check a little bit if I can I have
absolutely no chance to win him just I
mean do ring a little button and then
he's got rook on the fourth HSC draw
it's really just what it is
Thrun in g5 I mean there's no harm in
continuing but you don't really have an
akuna chance
you know trying to somehow at least
continue it it's not really positive
that he's doing it in the best possible
way but it is just to draw anyway if I
go up I actually risk to get checkmated
okay come on where's the drawer thing
here draw I have to actually yeah yeah
that was a little bit a little bit
disappointing because I had this
comfortable position and should try I
should get a little bit more like
roughly here
I'm just very comfortable and should I
should get a knot and I can win but some
serious winning ideas yeah so we got
this this of theoretical position and
Blackie now I think normally castles but
c3 is an option
he went Bishop e6 Queen a4 yeah c3 is a
possibility returned the pawn like that
my camp this this should be a little bit
better for me I'm not totally certain
might be also theoretically explored
position Queen him queen a3 it's not a
bad idea actually I did not think about
it Queen a3 which is covering this and
also happening in I on the night I'm not
threatening to take it all that much but
maybe I do yeah anyway this was a good
or charge of Bishop g3 and
yeah he took with this queen here and
now Knight f5 from 95 yeah this is
definitely a bit better for me but I'm
not not certain about the best
continuation I could have taken here but
he's going to do this and I thought here
I have 97 I didn't see that I was only
seeing this one and I thought that is
probably not a serious winning attempt
one issue is that the knight does not
have a good square really I mean I
needed some soon when F weight doesn't
do much and I'm not getting it into him
on to a decent square like e3 for
example wouldn't be bad if it is a
secure square but I don't get it them
and this is better anyway take and now
um yeah that was not easy to decide I
think that c6 was probably right and
it's also given by the comp um I felt
that this should be better for me as
well but I couldn't quite figure it out
one thing that I saw I said I can maybe
get it here which is a nice post for for
the night it's tough to say I mean I
have to be a little bit better but if it
is better or worse then the capture on
c6 is really tough the same yeah here
this is a very comfortable situation
where you just press for four no one
particularly without any particular risk
I thought I can just pile up but maybe I
should take it I mean I saw that I saw
this line and I felt like my winning
chances here are not high I'm a little
bit surprised that the engine is giving
Luke a one I was thinking if he does
that toying with this idea I would have
an issue here I understand that there's
a back rank made but let's say I fought
here and he would play something like
that
and hmm yeah I don't think you can win
this I have to play rook everyone okay -
yeah well you can take off p1 and it's
clearly better for white Oh anyway maybe
I should have done that and also I
recommend áown a little bit this is why
I played some quick moves quick and safe
moss but probably I should really just
take on c7 huh oh yeah I can actually
yeah man I didn't didn't spot that long
okay what's panicking a little bit
I didn't see that this is the pond yeah
and then we got to go to this ending
where black should be okay probably this
is not enough - yeah and here the black
is okay of course and you played that a
somewhat silly Moo g5 but it's it's like
yeah you're not it's just like you're
going getting nowhere it's all on one
side of the board and even even every
wouldn't have had a double pawn the
winning chances are absolutely minimum
okay guys thanks for watching